Let us now discuss a little bit
the simplest estimation
problem that there is, the
problem of estimating the mean
of a certain probability
distribution, and we will take
this occasion to introduce some
additional terminology
and discuss some desirable
properties of estimators.
So the context is as follows.
We have n random variables
that are independent, and
they're identically
distributed.
They are drawn from some
distribution that has a
certain mean theta and
some variance.
We assume that we do not know
the value of the mean, and we
want to estimate it.
The most natural way of
estimating the mean is to form
the sample mean, that is, we
take the n observations and
take their average.
Notice, that this quantity, the
sample mean or, in this
case, it is the estimator that
we're using, is a random
variable because its value is
determined by the values of
the random variables
X1 up to Xn.
Let us discuss some properties
of this estimator.
The first property is that the
expected value of this
estimator is equal
to the true mean.
This is because the expected
value of each one of the Xs is
theta, and therefore, the
expected value of this ratio
is theta as well.
Now, this is a relation
that's true for all
possible values of theta.
Let us appreciate the content
of this statement.
Let us think what this
expectation actually is.
More generally, suppose that
we're dealing with some
estimator, which is some
function of the data.
Then, the expected value of this
estimator is using the
expected value rule, and
assuming that we're dealing
with a discrete random variable
X, the expected value
of theta hat is determined
as follows.
And so we see that the expected
value for estimator
depends, or is affected,
by what the true
value of theta is.
So this is a quantity that
generally depends on theta.
And what we want in order to
have a so-called unbiased
estimator is that no matter
what theta is, this
expectation evaluates
to the true unknown
value equal to theta.
In general, having this
property, having an unbiased
estimator, is a desirable one.
We do not want our estimates to
be systematically high or
systematically low, no
matter what the true
value of theta is.
A second property of
the sample mean
estimator is the following.
By the weak law of large
numbers, we know that the
sample mean converges to the
true mean in the sense of
convergence in probability.
Once more, this is a property
that's true, no matter what
the underlying unknown value
little theta is.
When this is true, this
convergence is true, for all
values of little theta, then we
say that our estimator is
consistent or that we
have consistency.
Having a consistent estimator
is definitely a
very desirable property.
We would like, when we obtain
more and more data, that our
estimator will give us
the correct value.
Finally, we would like to say
something about the size of
the estimation error.
This is measured--
one way of measuring it, but
which is the most common, it's
measured in terms of the
mean squared error.
So theta is the unknown value.
This is our estimator.
This is the error.
We square the error, and
we take the average.
What we've got here for this
specific example of the sample
mean estimator is
the following.
Since it is unbiased, we have
a random variable minus the
mean of that random variable,
so this is just the variance
of the estimator.
And for the sample mean, we
know that its variance is
sigma squared over n.
So this gives us some very
specific knowledge about how
the mean squared error behaves
as we change n.
In this particular example, the
mean squared error did not
depend on theta.
It's the same no matter what
the true theta is.
But in other situations and
with other estimators, you
might actually obtain here
a function of theta.